j'ai besoin de travailler cinq morts
dans le département a déjà des dizaines
de milliers de sans abri tentative
d'évaluation du désert pages spéciales
dans ce journal sur ce drame nous
verrons comment s'organise la solidarité
et comment on peut aider la guadeloupe
quoi le vatican a tranché dans la sphère
du père noël d'auschwitz les accords
doivent être écrites en robe et les
carmélites doit quitter le camp lors de
la crise de conscience à propos des abus
sexuels sur les enfants
on n'en parle plus facilement et
structures il en parle et rit
bonsoir cinq morts de très nombreux
blessés 25000 sans abri c'est le bilan
provoquée par les ravages terribles du
cyclone hugo
le bilan pour la seule guadeloupe cela
donne une idée des dégâts provoqués dans
toutes les villes des caraïbes
et pourquoi ce soir nous avons décidé de
consacrer une page spéciale à ce drame
dans notre édition est tout d'abord pour
prendre conscience de la réalité de la
violence de la nature au cours de cette
nuit de samedi à dimanche et bien voici
le reportage de notre envoyé spéciaux
agnès poirier dominique merlin dans la
petite localité de la moule l'une des
plus touchées en désespoir de cause elle
est venue ce matin la mairie les mains
vides car comme tous ici
elle n'a plus rien
nos visites et nous revoir adhérer bon
alors on est venu pour nous offrir
on arrive tous veulent voir madame le
maire lui parler trouver à manger pour
leurs enfants
une madame carabins maire du moule n'a
rien pour eux ni abri ni nourriture
alors quand ils viennent nous avons des
débats mettant devons alors comment cela
nous organiser de manière que des bulles
deux bénévoles dans chaque section la
charente
la petite ville du moule est aujourd'hui
un champ de bataille
tout a disparu lusine de canne à sucre
qui faisait vivre le village n'existe
plus il n'y a plus de magasins plus
l'église et la caserne des pompiers a
brûlé l'arrière boutique de la
boulangerie est prise d'assaut
on veut du pain nous dit cet homme
il y à de la farine mais pas
d'électricité impossible de faire
marcher pour les habitants du moule sont
presque tous à la rue on dort n'importe
où cette famille de cinq enfants s'est
réfugié à l'école ils ont quitté leur
maison de planches et de tôles qui se
disloquer en prenant avec eux quelques
vêtements
et c'est tout j'ai des broyats
débrouille avec les enfants
entre le désespoir et la résignation
les habitants du moule attendent
voilà pour cette page spéciale ce soir
nous avons plusieurs invités bien sûr et
nous aurons par exemple tout à l'heure
nous parlerons avec laurent voulzy avec
julien clerc et avec marie josé pérec de
la solidarité mais tout de suite je
m'adresse à au ministre des dom-tom
monsieur le pensec tête en direct de
pointe à pitre
monsieur le ministre est ce qu'on peut
ce soir perd une évaluation assez précis
des dégâts
je voudrais tout d'abord vous dire que
je me suis trouvé hier dans la commune
du moule précisément le lieu des images
que vous présentiez tout à l'heure que
j'ai rencontré bien sûr madame le maire
et la population et que les images sont
suffisamment éloquentes qu'il n'est
point besoin d'ajouter à ce qui peut
être le sentiment de détresse de la
population
je voudrais vous dire puisque je sors de
la réunion du pc opérationnel que nous
cernons un peu mieux mais ce n'est
qu'une évaluation approximative
le nombre des sans abri on peut
considérer que plus de vingt mille
personnes sont à ce jour dénombré comme
sans abri il y à de très nombreuses
familles dans la détresse
je passe parce que le bilan a déjà été
fait hélas dramatique au niveau des
pertes en vies humaines et des blessés
dont certains gravement mais ces
chiffres traduisent l'immensité la
lourdeur
il faut le dire de l'épreuve humaine qui
est infligé à à l'aquathlon alors
monsieur le pen voulait revenir en
détail on va pas revenir en détail sur
les mesures par la leur en parler avec
michel rocard
simplement j'aimerais vous demander est
ce que les uns des jeux là vous entend
aller vite pour la guadeloupe parce que
par exemple pour la réunion au cours du
dernier cyclone ça ne va pas été prévu
alors pour la guadeloupe et réveillera
vite
je voudrais vous dire que ça va vite
nous avons tiré les leçons d'un certain
nombre d'expériences et ne vous a pas
échappé qu'avant la fin du cyclone il
avait été pris un certain nombre de
mesure d'envois d'unités d'instruction
de la sécurité civile
elles sont en place précisément dans la
commune du moule quelques heures après
le reportage que vous y avez fait elles
sont donc à pied d'oeuvre et je me dois
de dire combien les mesures préventives
qui ont été prises ont permis de faire
que le désastre en termes de personnes
aient pu être qu'ils ont le mot limité à
ce qu'il est car la fureur de ce cyclone
pouvait nous met en présence d'une toute
autre réalité
merci monsieur ministère dela les
preneurs sur le site l'intervention du
président mitterrand il a donné un
communiqué tout à l'heure à l'elysée le
président mitterrand a affirmé à propos
de ce qui a été détruit à la guadeloupe
nous reconstruirons ensemble et
rapidement ce qui a été détruit c'est
donc cela confirme ce que vient de dire
le premier ministre monsieur le prince
est on va écouter aussi ce qu'a dit il
ya quelques minutes le premier ministre
michel rocard
à propos de l'aide à la guadeloupe
écoutez michel rocard nous sommes allés
très vite à prendre quelques décisions
l'une d'entre elles et le gel des
intérêts dus par l'ensemble des
habitants de la guadeloupe qui sont
coincés dans leurs paiements
une autre est le déblocage d'une
subvention d'urgence de 34 millions de
francs qui permettra de donner à chaque
famille une avance sur les indemnités
une troisième est un blocage des prix à
la guadeloupe pour trois mois pour
éviter que la spéculation ne s'y mettent
ça va un petit peu vite maintenant nous
avons un autre invité en direct de
pointe à pitre tout de suite c'est
madame lucette michaux chevry ancien
secrétaire d'état à la francophonie
bonsoir madame alors vous avez entendu
tous ces propos est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que l'aide pour la
guadeloupe va assez vite après ce
désastre qu'elle a connue est
contestable le boss ça va vite mais je
souhaite que ça aille plus vite parce
que lorsque j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
monsieur lepessec parler de report des
dettes jeudi que la france ait été très
généreuse pour l'afrique parce qu'elle a
annulé la dette du tiers-monde
l'économie guadeloupéenne est à plein à
la guadeloupe est sinistré depuis 76 je
vois que le moment est venu de mettre à
plat l'ensemble des dettes de ce
département de recommencer avec des
prêts sous 10 15 ans sans intérêt pour
reconstruire la voix de lou il ne peut
pas être question de gérer les taudis et
de gérer la rénovation de l'habitat
insalubre
c'est ça ma préoccupation faire très
vite et met les guadeloupéens au travail
en passant je dis heureusement que nous
sommes français parce que aujourd'hui
faire fait qu'ils prêchent indépendance
de la guadeloupe se rendent compte que
la solidarité nationale n'est pas un
vain mot et que de partout en métropole
nous recevons des appels de solidarité
et cela réconforte le coeur de nos
compatriotes guadeloupéens très
rapidement vous avez proposé des mesures
fiscales pour aider les guadeloupéens
mais et écouter la moelle loupe et
d'endetter les entreprises que ce soit
l'économie bananière sucrière l'économie
touristique
il y a des dettes fiscales ya des dettes
sociales énormes
si nous voulons relancer l'économie de
la guadeloupe il faut éponger les dettes
je ne vois pas pourquoi on fait des
cadeaux aux africains japon elle ne
ferait pas des cadeaux à ce morceau de
la france
et a fait mille kilomètres de la
métropole merci madame merci bien de
tous côtés en tout cas la solide et la
solidarité pardon se manifeste déjà les
associations antillaises de paris sont
presque submergées témoin ce reportage
d'eric perrin et de véronique et l'yonne
tout le monde d'accord merci beaucoup
madame 500 francs pour les six lycées de
la guadeloupe dont la valeur famille ou
leurs amis ils sont venus donner chacun
selon ses moyens
quel est le profil type du donneur 20
des gens du simple et surtout ici on a
travaillé toute la nuit
la solidarité n'est pas seulement
antillaise elle est nationale et on
pense à mes amis qui sont là bas chez
venu parce que effectivement et puis les
bras et vous avez vu ce qu'ils en ont
besoin
puis ces chats bookmakers quoi c'est là
bas mais on à bruno turc est là bas et
mes copains ben je pense à lui en étant
ici en 48 heures plus de 20 tonnes de
nourriture vêtements et outils ont été
apportées ici 500 tonnes de pommes
attendent d'être embarqué à marseille
dès demain les colis partiront pour la
guadeloupe presque victime de son succès
et sow et sugot travaillent 24 heures
sur 24 pour collecter stocker le
matériel plus de 800 tonnes au total de
la nourriture des lits du ciment des
planches
parmi les donateurs beaucoup de
particuliers mais aussi des entreprises
démarchées par les membres de
l'association
ces trois tonnes de vivres ont été
offertes par une grande surface
la mairie de stains prête des locaux
pour centraliser le tout
dès le départ j'avais dit la solidarité
alité national on se rend compte qu'elle
est national et ce que j'ai envie de
dire c'est que les outre-mers peuvent
penser qu'en france bien les
métropolitains sont des frères et sauvé
sur goût recherche actuellement un moyen
pour faire parvenir le matériel le plus
rapidement possible elle a besoin
également de bénévoles et soes hugo 40e
2 43 54 70 tropiques fm 43 63 23 35
les artistes les sportifs ne sont pas en
reste surtout ceux qui ont des attaches
particulières avec les antilles c'est
pourquoi nous avons réuni trois d'entre
eux marie josé pérec laurent voulzy et
julien clerc aux côtés de pascal
deschamps il se trouve en direct avec
nous sur la péniche qui s'appelle bébé
antilles un restaurant antilles et sur
l'eau tout près du pont de sèvres alors
d'abord marie josé pérec bonsoir vous
êtes guadeloupéen vous même n'est ce pas
satisfait du pn vous avez des de la
famille l'avant ce moment là oui j'ai
mon père la grand-mère et le reste de ma
famille
vous avez eu de nouvelles d'eux
aujourd'hui j'ai eu des nouvelles de la
famille il se porte très bien sûr en
jugeant que comme temps sur la région de
basse-terre ça n'a pas été
c'est très dur pour eux enfin il se
portait bien vous êtes inquiet peut
inquiète pardon pour d'autres familles à
vous ben justement parce que j'ai vu que
sur la grande terre enfin disons qu'elle
a été très touché
enfin si c'est comment dire je pense
qu'il faut t'y folie des 10 alors à vos
côtés il ya julien clerc et laurent
voulzy julien clerc tout ce qui se passe
aux antilles vous touche on sait oui non
enfer et et enquillait j'ai pas mal de
familles là-bas beaucoup de sa famille à
lui en particulier et cousines et toute
sa famille que j'ai revu quand je vais
aller chanter la dernière île laurent
voulzy vous alors aussi bien sûr on sait
que d'infimes ou touch
bien sûr j'étais fabriquer là-bas et
même si je suis né ici j'étais fabriquer
là-bas aux antilles en guadeloupe et bon
moi j'essaie d'avoir des nouvelles
évidemment j'étais très inquiet j'avais
j'étais en communication au père perdre
pop perpétuellement avec ma mère au
téléphone qui habite à paris qui était
très inquiète parce que j'ai un frère
qui était dans la ville la plus touchée
de la guadeloupe qui était à saint
françois qui a été entre la ville a été
pratiquement rasée quoi donc
lui il est à 5 km de saint françois et
j'ai touché toujours pas eu au téléphone
mais par par des coups de téléphone
passant par la martinique
j'ai su qu'il allait bien avec sa femme
et est
et son fils mais j'ai aussi beaucoup de
familles là-bas alors effectivement
beaucoup plus sur la basse terre parce
que je suis originaire d'un petit
village qui s'appelle capesterre le même
que julien clerc enfin ma famille est
originaire de là-bas donc la plupart de
la famille est effectivement sur la base
des termes imagine que vous devez d'être
devait d'être inquiet donc simplement je
voulais vous demander à vous deux
artistes on pense par exemple à la
chanson de laurent où il parle de la
désirade qui a été lancée à travers
égales entre marie galante bien se
régale en quoi diffère beaucoup aussi
oui et qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
vos artistes on a il ya certains cas
staff par exemple propose de faire un
concert et terrestres vous seriez
d'accord aussi
oui bon on ne se donne la première fois
que j'entends parler partout ce soir
pourquoi pas mais je crois que en n'est
pas uniquement des chanteurs ceci vous
avez demandé de venir dans votre journal
ce soir c'est aussi pour aider à
sensibiliser les gens je crois que les
gens ont déjà montré qu'ils étaient
sensibilisés c'est bien mais je crois
qu'on peut toujours faire plus c'est
notre pays je pense que tous les
français en la guadeloupe dans le coeur
les antilles en dehors de l'image
idyllique qu'on en a souvent ici ya
aussi une autre réalité il y installe
pee wee à 30 % de chômage est et où il
ya beaucoup de pauvres et
c'est tour à gand qui est passé sur la
guadeloupe hier et qui est une des
fatalités des antilles qui se répète
bien souvent fait que deux des familles
entières ont perdu leur maison qui s'est
envolé comme ça des frigidaires volant
dans les pièces des gens se réfugient
dans des armoires les pêcheurs ont perdu
leur bateau il ya beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de petites gens des
gens qui sont pauvres la vague qui ont
évidemment besoin l'aide
merci beaucoup à tous les trois merci
julien clerc merci laurent voulzy merci
ma jeune marie josé pérec j'espère
justement votre ennemi témoignage aura
servi à encourager tous les français à
la solidarité
en tout cas je vous le disais après
avoir dévasté la guadeloupe le cyclone
hugo a poursuivi sa route les îles
vierges porto rico d'autres il encore et
puis maintenant il se dirige vers la
floride
partout la mort et la désolation au
total au moins 25 morts surtout ce
trajet et des milliers et des milliers
de sans abri philippe boisserie un
voyage dévastateur qui n'en finit plus
après la guadeloupe
hugo a marqué de son empreinte d'esprit
de nombreuses îles des caraïbes petit
clown a tué deux personnes à antigua et
6 à montserrat dans cette île
britannique les 12000 habitants se
retrouvent sans toit privés
d'électricité de vivres d'eau potable
même l'hôpital a été détruit après avoir
soufflé les îles vierges
hugo s'est attaqué à porto rico où un
premier bilan fait état de quatre morts
certains parlent même de 25 victimes
pour les cinquante mille sans abri le
spectacle est désolant mais ont décapité
arbres arrachés voitures submergées à la
campagne
aucune récolte n'a résisté aux assauts
du vent sur l'aéroport les avions semble
avoir été soulevé comme des feuilles
dans les rues les militaires protègent
des pillards les magasins éventrés
ce soir si saint domingue épargné
respirent les bahamas attendent avec
angoisse un hugo qui avance à près de 20
km heure
l'inquiétude gagne même les états unis
c'est là que go pourrait choisir de
s'éteindre
en revanche un autre cyclone menace est
aussi les antilles il s'appelait qui
s'appelle toujours iris cette fois mais
heureusement ils ne savent attrapa sur
ces régions les métérologues annonce
qu'il passera au large
dernier volet notre page spéciale
quelques explications techniques il en
faut la violence du go mérite bien qu'on
s'interroge sur ces phénomènes
car il est bien possible que ces
phénomènes climatiques deviennent de
plus en plus violents au fil du temps
tout simplement parce que les hommes
abîme de plus en plus l'atmosphère
explications de patrick esther
les cataclysmes sont de plus en plus
fréquent cyclones inondations ou vague
de sécheresse
faut-il y voir un hasard malheureux ou
une évolution du climat
aujourd'hui les scientifiques pensent
qu'il existe bel et bien un lien étroit
entre les inondations du pérou l'absence
de mousson en inde ou encore les
hurricanes qui ravage les antilles tout
se passe comme si chacun de ces
événements climatiques provoqués un
contrecoup à l'autre bout de la planète
l'atmosphère du globe ces mouvements
d'air chaud ou d'air froid sont
fortement influencées par les océans que
ceux ci connaissent des élévations
brutale des températures et les
catastrophes surviennent par exemple
lorsque les autres piques à la taille
26° 5
ainsi claude se développe récemment les
chercheurs ont découvert un phénomène
mystérieux qui l'ont baptisé el niño un
échauffement anormal de l'eau du
pacifique qui provoque un déséquilibre
atmosphérique et perturbent le climat de
l'amérique du nord et du sud
or actuellement la terre se réchauffe
les sécheresses augmente mais les
ouragans deviennent plus destructeur une
frappe de plus en plus vers le nord
et cela durant une plus longue partie de
l'année
dans le réchauffement de la terre
l'activité humaine possède sa part de
responsabilité la production excessive
de gaz carbonique la destruction massive
des forêts contribuent à créer autour du
globe à effet de serre un piège pour les
rayons du soleil ce qui aboutit à
l'élévation globale des températures
alors même si l'on ne comprend pas
encore très bien tous les mécanismes on
peut affirmer que l'homme est en partie
responsable des malheurs qui le frappe
voilà donc pour cette page spéciale que
nous avions décidé ce soir de consacré à
la catastrophe de la guadeloupe et des
autres îles des antilles le réel de
l'actualité maintenant et tout d'abord
la sphère du carmel d'auschwitz
une étape décisive puisque lé vatican a
tranché aujourd'hui les carmélites
doivent déménager et s'installer hors de
l'ancien camp de concentration
c'est la première fois que les plus
hautes autorités catholiques prennent
position
depuis que les polonais remettait en
cause l'accord de 87
ce n'est pas jean paul ii qui a parlé
mais le communiqué du vatican vis du
vatican pardon est très claire
explications à rome de marcel trillât et
ensuite réaction de théo klein plusieurs
semaines de réflexion pour une prise de
position attendue
un délai qui trahit le déchirement de
jean paul ii ancien archevêque de
cracovie dont dépend le carmen
d'auschwitz et son souci de ménager la
susceptibilité des catholiques polonais
le texte du cardinal willebrand ce
président de la commission des relations
religieuses avec le judaïsme est
cependant sans équivoque ils se réfèrent
clairement aux accords de genève
il approuve le projet de centre
d'information de rencontre et de prières
comportant le futur monastère des
carmélites d'auschwitz ça c'est le point
central ce qui devrait être un élément
de paix nous espérons de réconciliation
prière d'éducation un exemple qu'on ne
s'interdisait pour l'europe entière même
temps les précautions d'usagé le
communiqué d'aujourd'hui est un
véritable désaveu pour le cardinal globe
le primat de pologne n'avait pas hésité
le 2 septembre dernier dans une
interview au quotidien italien la
repubblica a défié le vatican les soeurs
reste très vite affirmé t-il tout en
l'accusant d'incompétence les quatre
cardinaux qui avait signé les accords de
genève s'est communiqué du vatican met
fin à la querelle qui existait au sein
d'églises de tavan l'église polonaise
concernant les accords de genève
je pense qu'à partir de maintenant
personnes en pologne ou ailleurs ne
pourra mettre en doute la validité de
ses engagements pris par l'église
ratifié aujourd'hui par le vatican et
qui devront être mis en oeuvre
rapidement sur l'espère pour éviter de
nouveaux incidents
seule fausse note ce soir dans cette
affaire celle de monseigneur glen encore
lui il est opposé au départ forcé des
carmélites il a dit tout à l'heure en
angleterre où il se trouvait qu'il ne
pensait pas que ce que ce soit le moyen
de résoudre la situation ni parler bien
sûr du communiqué du vatican
les relations entre la france et la
pologne il en a été beaucoup question
aujourd'hui à varsovie puisque roland
dumas le ministre français des affaires
étrangères se trouve dans la capitale
polonaise monsieur dumas qui est aussi
l'actuel président du conseil de la cee
vient de signer un accord commercial
accord donc entre l'europe et la pologne
les relations commerciales entre nos
pays d'europe et la pologne vont donc
s'améliorer et s'accroît à moscou
journée importante surtout pour
gorbatchev c'était l'ouverture de la
session plénière du comité central du
pcc consacré aux problèmes des
nationalités
souvenez-vous les révoltes récentes en
arménie en azerbaïdjan en géorgie et
dans les provinces baltes entre autres
il semble que moscou s'apprête à
s'apprêterait à accroître l'autonomie de
toutes ces républiques
ce serait une réforme capitale en union
soviétique mais avant d'en venir à cette
question des nationalités le plénum ce
matin après une autre décision fixé la
date du prochain congrès du pc georges
bortoli monsieur gorbatchev contenu de
ce phenom que le prochain congrès du
parti ait lieu plus tôt que prévu il est
fixé à
octobre 90 dans un peu plus d'un an
d'ici là le parti de vivre dans la
fièvre car un congrès anticipé cela veut
dire des limogeages plus que probable
monsieur gorbatchev a d'ailleurs parlé
d'une grande refonte du parti monsieur
gorbatchev entretient donc les cadres du
parti dans la crainte des sanctions dans
le but évident de mieux assurer son
pouvoir
cela dit sur la question des
nationalités qui était à l'ordre du jour
du comité central il n'a pas été très
clair il admet les manifestations
nationalistes légitime
il condamne celles qui vont très loin
trop loin bref il essaie de garder une
position nuancée alors que sur tout le
pourtour de l'urss
on manifeste les nationalistes baltes
mène depuis 1988 une action dans le
calme
le caucase au contraire et le théâtre
également depuis 88 d'affrontements
interethniques sanglantes qui se sont
étendus depuis 1989 à l'asie centrale et
dernière venue la moldavie et l'ukraine
occidentale entendent barque elle aussi
leurs différences bref il y a urgence
certains en sont déjà à craindre à
moscou de voir un jour la russie se
retrouver tout seul sans ses possessions
périphériques dont certaines lui
appartient de même depuis deux siècles
c'est une des grandes inquiétudes à
moscou l'autre étant évidemment la
détérioration accélérée du niveau de vie
et du ravitaillement contre ces deux
préoccupations
il semble que monsieur gorbatchev n'est
pas pour l'instant de remettre de
miracle
merci georges et à l'instant cette
information dans vienne 30 connaissance
cette dépêche de la fp importante
un dc10 de la compagnie uta et ce soir
portés disparus le dc10 qui assurait la
liaison entre brazzaville djamena et
roissy n'a plus donné de ses nouvelles
depuis son décollage de ne jamais n'a
c'était cet après midi à 14 heures heure
de paris depuis donc plus de nouvelles
c'est de cet avion est pour l'instant il
est porté disparu avec un consignes et
maintenant nous allons voir d'autres
informations importantes de ce mardi en
bref et en images à commencer par la
prise d'otages près de liège
une famille retenue par trois gangsters
dont le fameux philippe delaire et les
ravisseurs le savant fallait
10h les truands le savent les 30
millions sont ici ap le 30 millions de
francs belges que selon le procureur du
roi la police était prête à verser comme
rançon aux ravisseurs de type mais les
trois hommes auraient refusé de libérer
d'abord les deux enfants qu'ils
détiennent depuis samedi avec leur mère
et ce soir les négociations sont
bloquées réapparition numéro un chinois
deng xiaoping après trois mois d'absence
samedi dernier il recevait un
scientifique américain est aujourd'hui
sur ces images un ancien ministre
japonais denso mettre en bonne santé est
critique la résolution adoptée par les
sept sur le massacre du printemps de
pékin
situation bloquée aujourd'hui encore à
peugeot la direction refuse d'ouvrir des
négociations après une journée de
réflexion
la confédération générale des cadres des
fils de ne pas appeler à la grève
pendant ce temps la direction de renault
décide d'avancer son propre calendrier
d'augmentation salariale audition
aujourd'hui des partenaires sociaux à
matignon paul marchelli président de la
cgc sort mécontents du bureau de michel
rocard
selon lui la politique du gouvernement
finalise les cadres françois périgot se
prononcera lui pour le cnpf dans
quelques jours
et ta fortune est aujourd'hui pour
françois mitterrand qu'il continue sa
tournée des capitales européennes
cinq heures de visite pour présenter les
priorités de la présidence française de
la cee entrevue avec le premier ministre
cavaco silva et le président mario
soares
+0 18% de hausse à la bourse de paris
perd sur des aujourd'hui par l'éruption
d'employés du trésor au congrès m
le dollar s'échange au cours officiel à
seafrance 61 55 je reviens un court
instant à l'ats cette information que je
vous donnais il ya quelques minutes un
dc10 de la compagnie uta qui a qui est
portée disparue j'ai plus de précisions
maintenant il s'agissait du vol ut 772
donc y relier bien brazzaville djamena
et roissy il devait arriver ce soir à
paris à bord il y avait cent cinquante
quatre personnes 140 passagers et 14
membres d'équipage
le dernier contact entre l'appareil et
le sol a eu lieu 20 minutes après le
décollage de djamena la capitale du
tchad depuis aucun contact avec le dc10
le décès si le dc10 a cessé d'émettre
plus aucune nouvelle depuis c'est
pourquoi l'avion est maintenant porté
disparu depuis l'année dernière un
effort est fait pour lutter contre les
abus sexuels sur les enfants aujourd'hui
c'était la journée nationale de l'enfant
sur ce sujet et on mesure que depuis les
forfaits l'an dernier sur ce grave
problème il y a eu une prise de
conscience
les enfants sont encouragés à parler de
ces sujets tabous et les centres de
thérapie pour les aider celui deeply un
exemple une situation terrible comme
toujours dans ces drames
une mère qui acceptait de parler de ce
que son mari a fait subir à sa fille
reportage d'anne 15 du rejet et france
brice est à jour
aline s'est mise à parler attire ce qui
lui arrive est ce son père lui faisait
qu'est ce qu'elle avait dit à lindsay
il est fou on perd et c'est pour ce
cadre la bouche ce sont des propos
qu'elle tient une chose qu'un hacker
vite parce que le désigne français ça
donne et non sans cesse ses manières sa
manière est de te parler
et de là donc j'ai consulté les cinq la
suite clément et toutes les pressions
judiciaires
c'est suivi la luminance se pensait pour
sauver mon enfant qui concerne pas
sauvée loin de l'être pour se rendre
compte de la lyre donc c'est très
dépensier la zone et je vais tout dans
ce sens maintenant on dire je vais la
sauver moi je vois rinça mais la justice
ne suit pas aline la justice pour le
juge d'instruction pour l'espère aussi
car comme pour la justice pour le sens
négatif qui travaille pour la justice a
in fine à faible et à six de même que
ainsi que - la mère s'est mondialisée il
faut sauver elle me dit à moi de dire
aux messins également le team personnes
qui assistent aux séances et ce sont ses
mots il faut me sauver je ne suis pas du
monde de hip hop soul et alors je lui
dis il n'y a aucun secret niane qui que
ce soit il faut toujours tout dire sur
tous les noms c'est très important
il faut sortir tous les enfants sénat
s'il faut surtout en mer comptant les
enfants qui n'ont aucun secret se
retrouve pas la relation mère enfant qui
selon lui est un jeu où il faut des
enfants l'énorme problème il faut les
aider
et c'est à la peine ce cours un grand
couturier qui se singularise c'est
giorgio armani
le chef de file des créateurs italiens
avec sa dernière collection automne
hiver
l'art de la mode rend hommage à l'art
des formes la collection armani était
présenté en effet au musée rodin c'est
de la sculpture le musée rodin est
d'habitude c'est ce qu'on voit dans ce
musée
marie-josée le picard et bernard pis son
nom pas rater cet événement qui mettait
face à face ou côte à côte comme doublé
2 art différent
dans les jardins illuminés du musée
rodin les fameux tailleur pantalon
les célèbres veston souple du milanais
giorgio armani ont défilé hier soir pour
le plaisir des clientes de sa boutique
parisienne invité là en tenue de soirée
ces silhouettes si simple qui ont tant
de succès pour qui giorgio armani et
rêve-t-il je pense mon homme qui a une
idéale de sa vie de soi-même d'elle-même
et qui s'habille par conséquent ce
savoir faire d'un défaut une qualité
faut avoir le courage nous présenter
comme n'est pas se camoufler derrière
quelque chose qui nous appartient pas
nous armani aussi utilisent les
références
cette saison les couleurs de paul poiret
les justaucorps brodé de la renaissance
mais il reste avant tout fidèle à son
époque un mode qui se développe
tranquillement avec sérénité garde
surtout l'esprit d'une femme qui est
moderne intelligente qui ne souffre pas
la mode n'est pas violé par la mode
un style qui depuis 1975 a changé les
critères de l'élégance italienne en deçà
des alpes et au delà
voilà je reviens un court instant au
premier sujet de ce journal c'est à dire
au drame de la guadeloupe vous avez été
très nombreux à nous appeler pour
pouvoir aider les sinistrés de la
guadeloupe et vous demandez les numéros
de téléphone que nous avons déjà donné
tout à l'heure alors tout de suite
prenez un crayon je vais voulait
redonner installez vous prenez un crayon
les voici ses numéros de téléphone ils
sont inscrits d'ailleurs sur l'écran sos
hugo c 42 43 54 70 ou alors tropiques fm
vous appelez le 43 63 23 35
voilà il y avait aussi un encore des
chiffres c'est le résultat du tiercé
quinté plus c'était aujourd'hui à
vincennes nous allons voir sur l'écran
le quinté + c'est fait 16 6 11 et 8 ça
c'est l'heure d'arrivée exactes et les
rapports les rapports on les a on les a
pas je ne sais pas non ne les a pas
d'ailleurs c'est assez compliqué alors
toute façon eh bien vous regarderez d'un
dernière édition peut-être voit la fin
de cette édition
alors tout de suite nous allons avoir la
météo avec laurent cabrol après quelques
pubs et puis aussitôt après le beau film
d'agnès varda sans point ni loi avec
sandrine bonnaire dans le cadre des
dossiers de l'écran présentés par
l'excellent paul amar à 23h30 ce sans
renier pour la dernière édition que les
matins de 1,7 à 6h30 comme chaque jour
m'a dit tu rames et gérard morin pour
les journées excellente soirée à demain
m